hundreds of roosters were rescued in the
northeast valley today police say they
were being used for cockfighting
we thank you for joining us here at six
i'm christian casares good evening i'm
brian loftis [ __ ] fighting which is a
crime here in the state of nevada is
when roosters are forced to fight with
blades attached to their legs
until one of the animals dies sachaloft
is live near kerry and lamb with more
sasha brian christian this is the house
where those
roosters were rescued today we're told
the man who lives here
was raising them to fight and was
involved in the cockfighting ring
himself officers first came here to
conduct a separate investigation today
when they discovered over 300 roosters
the animal cruelty department was then
called in police say many of the animals
had their combs and spurs removed for
fighting
and razors were also found on the
property to attach to their legs
a detective on scene described the
cruelty of having roosters in this
capacity
and why it's against the law the whole
purpose of raising roosters in this
regard is to fight them
it's done as gambling and pleasure and
just
attending these fights is a crime in the
state of nevada
and raising the roosters and having the
implements
for the animals to fight is additional
crimes
the man who was arrested is facing drug
related charges right now
police say more animal cruelty charges
are also expected to be added on
now another cockfighting ring was busted
on this same street back in 2018
four men were arrested in that case 440
roosters were rescued from that property
and 20 roosters were found dead for now
reporting live in the northeast valley
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now